euro klasse passt super gemacht
technologen jetzt kommt ihr natürlich
der typisches wetter in mir raus und
macht ihn rein
hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zur dritten folge fifa
ultimate team zusammen mit mir kontakt
ich wollte mal ein bisschen etwas
umstellen und zwar welcher letzte mal
hier ein bisschen stehen geblieben ich
wollte gucken der tempo 89 da wo ich mal
den sinclair einpacken der auch tempo
980 hat allerdings beim dribbling ein
wenig höher beim drin ist er gleich
allerdings ist er beim schuss besser und
beim kopfball besser von daher wenn er
da man auf ihnen läuft dann passt das
glaube ich wenn wir sonst noch so passt
alles oben ein rechtes mittelfeld ist
nicht so ganz toll wäre ich dein rechtes
mittelfeld überhaupt darf aber das nicht
so schnell
ich würde sagen ich mag den rockies mir
dass verteidiger ich pack team ans
mittelfeld neben geht sonst noch nicht
gut sonst passt eigentlich alles
vielleicht noch nach rechts außen links
außen die sagt eigentlich zwei
linksaußen
den kann ich mir sehr schnell der 290
tempo wie sag ich dir nicht drin
okay gut ich würde sagen so treten
mehrfach neuen rechts mittelfeld fällt
mir dazu auf alemannia den
herausgenommen sich so schwer getan hat
anlass von packe ich mal wein und einer
verteidigung der typ schnell hier welche
man braucht halt schnelle spieler die
hier ist schnell also hier jetzt nicht
schnell das heißt paragrafen nicht gut §
immer rein und tauschten dann einfach
mal mit dem hier
dann müsste das hassen eigentlich okay
so lässt sich das mal eben
dann würde ich sagen gehen wir sofort
wieder die online saison übrigens habe
ich das komplette projekt hier jetzt
road to glory genannt ich weiß
eigentlich beim road to glory startet
man aber mit neuen team und blauen group
und zur ruhe
aber ich dachte jetzt gleich schon neue
teams habe und hier so ich hab jetzt
keinen bock nochmal hier von vorne
anzufangen sag ich mal deswegen mache
ich das einfach hier mit den teams und
road to glory glory sage ich mal nicht
festgelegte glory kann ja fünf sterne
alles top sein oder road to glory kann
einfach nur sein ja bis sich messi hat
oder insoweit also das ist ja schon
relativ unterschiedlich kommt drauf an
wie man interpretiert ich sage einfach
mal rotte glory ist für mich wichtig
sagt okay jetzt das erreicht was ich
will wenn fifa team ist hammer wenn es
auch ein englisches team hier mein fifa
team ist geil und deswegen lasse ich das
jetzt einfach mal so dabei und dann hab
ich keine lust mehr auf fifa als ich
denke das wird sich noch ein wenig
hinziehen
sie bringen schon die dritte folge von
ultimate team hier die ich heute auch
insgesamt an diesem tag schon
aufgenommen habe und ja also ich hab mir
überlegt ja kombiniert das projekt
projektile road to glory und hab ich
auch schon in der ersten folge gesagt
dass nicht das zu nennen wollte
und na ja gut dann geht es los
blaue trikots gegen rote trikot von
united gegen fc h weiß nicht ich jetzt
sagen wenn man erst mal ein bisschen
druck hier fort am anfang kann ja auch
mal hier im pressing machen oder eine
sofortige beide seiten gesehen und auf
diese anzeigen konzentriert da wir eh
allgemein schneller überall aufgestellt
sind als er so wie ich das grad gesehen
hat also er hatte wirklich sehr langsame
spieler unter anderem carl lampert und
so weiter will ich sagen gewinn doch die
sprint duelle wenn er zum beispiel lange
bälle in den raum passt und das war
absätze es war hundertprozentig abseits
gut dass schon der fünf das nicht wir
haben spieler fällt dahin ja dadurch
mich passen mit raphael rausgelaufen
super dass felder so mitmacht ich rate
ihnen wie immer so mit den spielern ist
mir aufgefallen
und das war ganz schlicht den am bau
haben wir haben wir alle klasse klasse
gemacht super echt klasse
und das jetzt auch fieber passen und
klasse dass der typische schnellste
sinclair zwar kann jetzt einfach vom
verteidiger ihr weglaufen läuft den
strafraum rein klagt ihr super flanke
mit dem kopf gegen die laufrichtung und
der geht allerdings nicht rein
warum weiß mich fifa hat übrigens gerade
ein bisschen bei der typ einfach nur so
busch internet hat wenn ihr warum man
sich nicht einfach mal vernünftiges
internet kaufen kann und dann andere
leute quasi damit so belästigt jetzt
ermittelt das war klar und jetzt zieht
er wieder zurück um das war alter was
macht denn der torwart david de gea
gläubig
schießt das eine lange ecke jetzt müssen
wir ein bisschen kommen sozusagen ich
schicke die alemannia nach vorn ich
versuche hier relativ schnell einmal zu
kontern weil sie nicht kontern sondern
mit einem tor zu kontern sag ich mal
sehr schnell wieder 1 1 zu senken
nein wenn der papst durchgekommen werden
lassen sicheres leute da so schnell ich
dachte schon wenn er mir wieder so ein
ding jetzt seine ecke zum ein controller
die wand geschmissen
ich muss gar nicht dass der lennon bei
sich darin hat er doch ein paar schnelle
spieler an den außen und das super
herausgespielt bisher so nach dem
abschluss wenn ich aber klasse wenn man
danach gleich mal schafft jedoch nicht
direkt
nein ich hätte gehen können dann gut
carrick ecke haben wir haben wir das
drin der ist drin
klassik-fans morning ich habe gesagt ich
packe ihn rein weil er ist groß ich habe
es gesagt der letzten folge
klassenzimmer sofort jetzt hat die
antwort gegeben mit dem 1 1 können
erstmalig ein bisschen schön ihn kommen
lassen schauen was er so bringt und
damit sofort wieder den ball auch nicht
allerdings gleich wieder und zwar genau
dann drei zwei eins unter
sehr stressige spiel losgeht drauf dann
ein nein die drauf erklärt klasse super
bubi carrick carrick wert auf anders
anders sein ein schlechter pass in die
spitze und was das war das weiß ich
selber nicht
ich habe dann in die vollkosten
zupfkuchen wenn ich mir irgendwann weil
einen einen fan post dings machen würde
so ein postfach dann bitte alle kuchen
voll bock auf kufen gerade klasse
gemacht zu papas und der wahl meiner zu
gelangen
alter ist ein klein bisschen mehr jogger
hat mich geht es nicht aber nicht an ich
mache jetzt mal üblich sind team
pressing abseits
ja komm jetzt lass mich in ruhe
haha nein was war das denn ich wollte
nicht zudem spielen
zudem darf man das ist wieder so eine
situation klasse passt super gemacht
technologen jetzt kommt ihr natürlich
der typisches wetter im hier raus und
macht ihn rein den eigenen mann und der
steht im abseits und nein
warum läuft er informiere dieser
verdammte finger es kann nicht wahr sein
denn erst das kann echt die seit zehn
milliarden prozentiges 21 es ist mehr
als zehn milliarden prozent ein
das kann doch nicht sein der typ muss
sich geradezu glücklich schätzen muss
ich so ein up lachen einfach nur eine
junge was ist das für eine unfähigkeit
von diesem schwarzen spieler der nicht
im sturm habe er hat kann ich nicht wahr
sein junger der tipper zu einem glatten
aber egal irgendwie auch komisch dass
wir ihnen immer mit den gleichen passen
irgendwie aus kontern können
er ist einfach so ein typ ist er steht
mit 1000 leuten vorne aber denkt einfach
mal überhaupt nie an seine abwehr wieder
lückenhaft das ist ein pass und sagte
ich dann schon wieder durch egal
so super anders klasse balleroberung das
war schön band herzliches bands und den
hält der ich hatte dann im tor kann ich
okay gut müssen uns auf jeden fall so
anstrengend dass wir jetzt nachlegen
es kann doch nicht sein erhält echt
alles der typ jak daniel roger ist super
gemacht von dem verteidiger dessen name
ich nicht weiß habe ich eigentlich terry
dass walker terry wollte ich mir
eigentlich kaufen john terry war mir
dann allerdings für acht doch ein
bisschen zu teuer
das war wichtig dass wir ihn holen
müssen lässt kann schon sagen dass jetzt
eine tolle chance kommt weil ein paar
solche freiräume gerade hat scheiße
jedoch zum ball spielt im echten
vertreten so zu so klasse schön gemacht
und da kommt wieder der passende spitze
mit dem er die klar kommt so den
handball den haben wir ihn haben wir
haben alles los das kann das ist doch
auch ein elfmeter wenn ich vorhin für
diese scheiß schubsen lan 11n elfer
gegen mich bekommen habe er ist das auch
ein elfmeter das verstehe ich die welt
was die sich dafür prioritäten setzen
was die ganze scheiße da soll aber sonst
ist das spiel echt geil das muss ich zu
sagen übrigens für die lecks aber da
kann ich nichts für das es einfach der
typ mit seinem internet das merkt auch
selber hier im spiel dass ich teilweise
so als spieler einfach mal stehen
bleiben
es seien ganz witzig auf jeden fall vor
allem der typ kriecht er trotzdem nicht
geschissen scheiß egal ob dem gutes und
schlechtes internet hat naja proalter
ich kann mich immer noch so aufregen
über die chance von vorhin dass sie
nicht reingemacht habe illegal los
weiter geht's jetzt schnell sprinten
spenden spenden
nein der andere soll die nehmen sehr
schöner ball schön aber ich verstehe das
nicht die sind mein komplette fifa logik
wird auf den kopf gestellt bei dem ich
verstehe dass der für pässe spielt ich
will pässe die kommen im leben nicht an
ich jetzt nicht gewundert wenn jetzt von
da geschossen hätte naja ok ich würde
sagen ich wechsele mal kurz ein bisschen
umwelt dieser komische typ der mir rein
gelaufen ist es klingt nicht wahr sein
und deswegen bekomme ich nachher sogar
noch abzüge in der abwehr besser
das regt mich ein bisschen auf denn hier
noch houellebecq könig im sturm bringen
sinclair war sehr gut der 3ds mehr
denkbar dass bestimmte vorne oxlade als
linken flügel nochmal so sinclair sonst
noch so habe ich noch aber desto mehr
zufrieden klar hinten gut wie ich sagen
wechseln erst mal nur zwei aus das voll
auf das man das nicht überspringen kann
smalling wie geht's dir allein
ausgewechselt auch schön
okay gut ein bisschen druck so geht man
definitiv nur defensiv und ich hoffe
sehr offensiv sehr defensiv schöner pass
ich dachte wir super gemacht
schöner pass glück dass er noch
angekommen ist
wer jetzt aber jetzt aber so das kann
doch nicht sein wie solche hinter dem
zimmer sowie schießt ein spieler den hin
die muss ja ganz einfach reinschieben
und nicht mit voller power auf dem
torwandschießen
solange kein gegentor kassieren ist mir
das alles noch wirkt das alles noch in
ordnung aber wenn der 1 kassieren dann
wäre aber böse weil wir dann die ganzen
chance nicht genutzt haben nein das kann
da läuft dir einfach wieder zurück eine
abwehr denkt der angriff sei schon
längst vorbei ich verstehe dass
teilweise echt nicht was es hier
teilweise soll dass es für eine fifa
logik ist ja gut okay vielleicht
passiert ja nun das 1 entsteht der da
wieder mit seinem kopf ich kann ich
schaffe es nicht die unfair wir ja jetzt
wird schießt das tor
na das wäre einfach so klar gewesen bei
meinem ganzen glücklich jetzt euch
versprechen können das erst tor schießt
und was ist das für ein abschlag ich
schieß genauso den gleichen abschlag die
sonst sind natürlich nur hier ja und er
läuft aufs tor zu und klar und da ist
das ein gutes handy aber auch glück
gehabt aber das gleicht sich nicht aus
mit dieser scheiß chance nicht wieder
vorhin hatten und die vertändelt haben
das war super gemacht das war richtig
klasse gemacht
es war richtig geil jedoch hin hierhin
online dass das ich reg mich in sachen
aufnahme besser ich drücke einmal kreis
und fünf sekunden später nimmt er das an
diesem pc mit seinem blöden internet
klasse gemacht lassen balleroberung bis
jetzt schnappte ich mir den ball jetzt
so ein bisschen pressen los presse haben
wir haben war schön wenigstens noch ein
spieler der hier noch was ein bisschen
was bringt auch klasse pass in den
rücken der abwehr
jetzt steht da keine er ist ich könnte
ausrasten
ohne scheiß ich könnte gerade echt schon
wieder so richtig das ist doch nein
natürlich ist kein foul
und da steht dann wieder einer im wege
es ist einfach mittlerweile so klar es
ist meine bestimmung dass immer
irgendeinen weg steht
ich bin der torwart ich halt jeden ball
hallo danke so haben wir guckt jetzt
habe ich wieder den ball
das ist einfach so unvermögen von dem
spieler der laster immer hält einer sein
fuß sein kopf dazwischen dass der ball
nicht dahin geht wo ich will
ob's im tor ist ob es ein ganz normaler
plus ist es ist einfach egal dabei die
bälle einfach nie an was ich mache jetzt
richtig druck stehen jetzt noch
ausgeglichen hier und verlierst mal
zeigt den ball richtig giftig so das
wissen was auf unten auf einmal ist da
unten keiner männer mein komplettes team
ja gerade nicht einfach nur auf
so kommt man jedoch nicht dachte der
ball kommt es an
das ist total absurd es gewesen wenn
bald von mir hier angekommen wäre
das letzte spiel jetzt habe ich mich
anders ab herausgeholt aber hat mir
wieder gut
klasse gemacht und scheinbar kommt sie
in der mitte macht gleich ein tor
schöner pass um luxus klasse ball super
applaudiert ihm sogar sein gegenspieler
mein gott und dann springt der daran
vorbei ich glaube es ja wohl nicht
und dann ist da ich drücke kreis als ich
da oben war und er nimmt das netz an und
schießt den ball dann erst mal drüber
auch sehr geil vor allem mittlerweile
hat es echt zu alle zwei sekunden also
ganz kurz auch schön aber ich merke
jetzt mittlerweile dass er auch davon
betroffen ist sieht man an seiner
spielweise seit man muss sagen mein team
spielt ja nicht schlecht für die
komplette organisation ist einfach so
viele chancen verwerten sein und das
zweikampfverhalten das nicht irgendwie
hat am meisten ist einfach keine
zweikämpfe mehr gewinn aus seiner abwehr
ich weiß eine abwärme kann man erst mal
sagen wichtiger jetzt scheiße scheiße
aber ich will natürlich auch ein tor
machen wir brauchen ja siege um
irgendwie diese saison hier zu gewinnen
12 ja ja eh läuft es gar nicht mal seine
weiß einer dazwischen hat einerseits
alter ist kann die zeit habt ihr das
gesehen
ich habe viermal geschossen und immer
liegt da irgendeiner mit seinem scheiß
kopf im weg das kann doch nicht wahr
sein krieg jedoch die krise wann solche
gegner schon seine die sich jetzt wegen
song la kings in der dinge in stratton
oder jetzt das spiel vielleicht sogar
noch gewinnen weil ich so klein bin ja
und jetzt macht er 100 prozent das tor
bis da es ist einfach so klar das kann
nicht wahr sein
jetzt ohne scheiß mahne ich könnte mich
so aufregt
ohne witz ich bin das komplette spiel
besser ich habe milliarden chance ich
hatte eine milliarden chance und meine
spieler schießen sich die ganze zeit
gegenseitig an ließ dem torwart eine
fresse und er hat einfach so ein scheiß
lag das enttäuscht ich hab's euch
prophezeit ich habe es gesagt ja wenn es
nach noch ein tor ich habe es gesagt
oder witzig habe es gesagt dieses
gekommen er hat ein tor geschossen
ich habe wieder einen fuß dazwischen ich
bin scheiß gegner junge wie mich das
schon wieder an pisst alter das sind so
momente da nicht aber die controller und
schmeißt man mir jetzt auf dem tisch
sondern freistoß er kriegt die gelbe
karte unendlich bisher noch die ganzen
falls am anfang als ich jedoch keine
gelbe karte nach fünf minuten egal wie
schlimm das war ich bin der
schiedsrichter
was ich passe jetzt einfach mal und zwar
um den ball noch ein bisschen im spiel
zu halten
da kommt jetzt sogar eine täuschung
warum jetzt gehen da fünf leute auf den
drauf fragt sich was ist das denn für
ein behinderter penner ohne scheiß mit
dem strich jetzt erst mal eine nachricht
die junge eben karte spitz voll unfair
und sodann kann ich überhaupt nicht
verlieren wird das video youtube
gesperrt alter wie kann man nur so ein
glück haben ist nicht wahr sein
jetzt drückt er nicht mehr auf gigs das
sind die größten
meine fresse drückt auf den scheiß
button an so kann man jetzt weiter
sein bester mann der torwart der torwart
von ihm hat 91
guckt euch seine abwehren 54 und so
guckt euch meinen spielern 82 ihr alter
ist kann nicht sein das kann echt nicht
wahr sein
ich krieg sogar noch 703 münzen sogar
mehr als vorhin als ich gewonnen habe
daran sieht man richtig dass ich besser
aber er hat kann ich nicht weniger
kommerziell weiter spiele details 16
schüsse 16 davon zwölf aufs tor er hat
vier shows off tor macht zwei tore ich
habe 2008 ein tor ich hab mehr
ballbesitz er zwar mehr zweikämpfe
gewonnen aber guckt euch das an
passgenauigkeit mal besser
schussgenauigkeit besser
und dann macht er so einen scheiß wetter
gollwitzer mann mann mann mann mann
größte bullshit
naja egal das war erstmal mit fifa bei
jungs seiner karriere den
nationalmannschaftskader von bulgarien
kanada vista was wir ziehen jetzt mal
eben hier so einen peg so kam ein
päckchen da kann ich mich ein bisschen
abreden aufregt so werden jetzt erstmal
bisschen gewinn gemacht das heißt das
ganze mit münzen
wenn der jetzt kein guter spieler der in
burgdorf paulinho hat ist der name
paulinho
das alles nur bullshit hier der spielt
in england dem papier seinen verein
mainz brauche ich nicht shooting oder
besser sehr choupo moting wollen nicht
aus man spielt auch in england beim
reitverein vertrag vertrag manager
vertrag für den löw heilung spieler
heilung alle verletzungen
ich muss mein verein der position kann
ich eigentlich listen ich weiß nicht wie
viel man die verkaufen kann
lass es einfach mal bei 600 anfangen
juventus turin trikotsatz kein bock alle
verbleibenden objekte verkaufen so
freunde wir kaufen noch ein pack ich
will es einmal das was gutes drin also
wieder 7000 oder münzen rathaus und es
schwer ist das k7 richard geppert habe
ich schon mal gehabt britos relativ
intakt ball hermann berding kann ich mir
theoretisch erst mal in die aktive
mannschaft den theoretisch erst mal
packe ich habe jetzt zeit mich gar kein
manager das heißt die packt erstmal rein
haben vertrag vertrag vertrag eine
modifikation ich hoffe mal dass es 4 4 2
oder so die kammer von der menge
verkaufen fitness karten meinte tier ja
kann ich immer ganz gut gelistet
lass das mal 200 anfangen 352 es nicht
naja verwehrt klar nein
der jetzt bestimmt gut na gut okay meine
liebe freunde ich würde sagen dass war
es erstmal in den speicher ich einfach
mein verein hat war es erstmal mit fifa
hier paart drei oder vier unter par 3
silber mittlerweile von der road to
glory wenn die tipps kommentare den
kommentare schreiben gibt enorm hoch
ausgefallen als beim nächsten mal
tschüss sie